und ich aber letztes mal für donald
trump gestimmt und das bedauerlich er
ist ein desaster lügt und twittert er
weigert sich auf ärzte zu hören deshalb
sind tausende an corona gestorben oder
erkrankt so wie mein vater
wir haben unsere freiheit verloren weil
donald trump versagt hat amerika geht es
nicht besser als vor vier jahren
ich möchte mein leben zurück deshalb
stimme ich für den s p hat die nase voll
von einem präsidenten der seine
landsleute nicht vor der pandemie
schützen konnte einen präsidenten der
sich nicht von polizeigewalt und
rassismus distanziert sie hat sich
entschieden wahlkampf zu machen diesmal
für die andere seite
einmal in der woche demonstriert sie mit
gleichgesinnten
[Musik]
es ist sehr wichtig besonders die
polizeireform dass die polizei
brutalität unter kontrolle kommt und ich
denke joe biden wird eine menge tun um
der black brown community zu helfen
denise ist alleinerziehend und hat zwei
söhne
samy und mitchell corona zwingt sie zu
hause zu bleiben keine schule kein
sportverein gut dass es vor dem haus ein
basketballkorb gibt die gegend hier ganz
normale mittelschicht der nist arbeitet
für ein callcenter von zu hause aus sie
will da sein für ihre jungs wie essen
immer zusammen ich bin froh dass wir so
eine familie sind wir essen wirklich
immer mit allen am tisch ich habe nur
noch ein paar jahre und dann sind sie
wahrscheinlich aus dem haus die sorge
darüber was in ihrem land geschieht die
sorge um die zukunft ihrer söhne haben
demnächst zu ihrer wahlentscheidung
bewogen
[Musik]
es fühlt sich gut an so eine art
wiedergutmachung weil ich 2016 für trump
gestimmt habe die stimme war verschenkt
ich hoffe viele frauen machen dasselbe
wie ich es sind frauen wie den east die
diese wahl entscheiden könnten die
frauen aus amerikas vorstädten seit
jahrzehnten orte gepflegter
bürgerlichkeit herkunft soziale klasse
sind wichtig vielfalt er nicht suburbia
ist immer noch mal
[Musik]
hier wie überall im land hat trump vor
vier jahren gepunktet auch die frauen
haben mehrheitlich für ihn gestimmt
doch schon zu den midterms vor zwei
jahren änderte sich das bild mehr frauen
gingen zur wahl und welten vor allem
demokratisch seitdem tobt wieder im
wahlkampfmodus ist da alles er muss
kämpfen die umfragen sie nicht gut aus
für ihn und er kämpft auch um die frauen
fast flehentlich ich möchte euch um
einen gefallen bitten frauen aus den
vorstädten würdet ihr mich bitte mögen
bitte bitte bei der letzten wahl waren
es 44 tausend stimmen die in
pennsylvania den ausschlag gaben die
frauen für trump gibt es natürlich immer
noch und auch sie versuchen zu
mobilisieren
flyer vorbereiten frauen überzeugen ihre
stimme abzugeben
am ende könnte es auf jede einzelne
ankommen für die trump anhängerinnen hat
ihr präsident in den letzten vier jahren
alles richtig gemacht
präsident trump hat nichts getan um
jemanden zu demoralisieren oder zu
diskreditieren während der präsident war
respektiert das amt ich möchte keinen
sozialistischen staat das ist wirklich
meine hauptsorge und ehrlich ich möchte
auch nicht dass man gott aus diesem land
wegnimmt
ich liebe ihn und ich glaube die
demokratische partei möchte gott raus
haben ja ich bin eine weiße
amerikanische frau und dafür
entschuldige ich mich nicht auch wenn
die beiden leute wollen dass ich mich
dafür entschuldige ich tu's nicht
ich bin sehr sehr stolz eine weiße
amerikanerin auf der vorstadt zu sein
die für donald trump kämpft melinda
wulff war auch mal republikanerin
jahrzehntelang vor zwei jahren ist sie
aus der partei ausgetreten
jetzt steht in ihrem vorgarten an beiden
harris schild
[Musik]
ich war angewidert von trump und seiner
inkompetenz seiner unerfahrenheit seinem
mangel an moral seinem hang oder seinem
weg eine autokratie zwar angewidert von
der republikanischen partei weil die ihm
das alles erlaubt hat und so macht mir
linda mit 67 jahren zum ersten mal in
ihrem leben wahlkampf wie ich mich fühle
ich bin sehr nervös
bei vielen hier in der gegend sind die
briefwahlunterlagen noch nicht
angekommen einige fürchten dass trump
mit absicht für chaos sorgen könnte
frauen müssen wählen und sie müssen ihn
abwählen
was ist das wichtigste thema für dich
ich möchte nicht dass mir ein mann
erzählt was ich mit meinem körper machen
darf und mir meine rechte als frau weg
nimmt kaum jemand mit dem melinda an
diesem morgen spricht möchte trampel
siegessicher ist melinda aber nicht
viele könnten ihre meinung noch ändern
befürchtet sie dabei stehe doch so viel
auf dem spiel
das ist die wichtigste wahl überhaupt an
der ich jemals teilgenommen haben nicht
nur für mich persönlich sondern für die
zukunft unseres landes
die zukunft der demokratie es geht darum
unserer demokratie wieder leben
einzuhauchen
auch unsere wirtschaft es geht um leben
und tod
amerika vor einer schicksalswahl
so sieht das auch denise machen so einen
schlechten eindruck niemand beneidet uns
mehr so wie früher aber ich denke wenn
wir am dritten november gewählt haben
haben wir wieder etwas auf das wir stolz
sein können
amerika wieder stolz machen das sollte
der neue slogan sein
es ist der ton die unversöhnlichkeit die
längst auch bei den frauen und in den
vororten angekommen sind in philadelphia
überwiegend zwei wochen vor der wahl die
beiden schilder auch in denise
nachbarschaft und das lässt sie
irgendwie hoffen
[Musik]